The million dollar question that,
every developer has to ask themselves
is, where do I put my breakpoints?
Defining breakpoints based on specific
devices, products, brand names or
anything else, will almost always
result in a maintenance nightmare.
You never know what next
hot device will be or
what will be hot two years from now.
>> Instead, look at the content
to find the right breakpoints.
Scott Yale said it best.
We shouldn't choose break points at all.
Instead, we should find them,
using our content as a guide.
Pete, I would love to get some insight,
into the choices that you
make when you're trying to decide,
what breakpoints to use on a page.
>> Sure.
Let's take a look.